[Music]
can drive avoid
Oh
I live around
here
you're in trouble okay you can't be a
resistance that came back my baton right
away
I'm not going too fast
whoa
look at my base look at your bank
there is
it's my time to tell her I
follow
so on your side you can't
this movement writer that long wet feet
they're not happy
so I have to keep finding there it is
right there
you know you get some undercut punch me
Oh
through right there do not have it
[Music]
but I learned it on the on the second
time okay
through there oh
thank you
hold it
that helps my straight
[Applause]
so just a she's trying to find the black
and you're really sick
she finds the blend we do it it
who that we want to stop yes
we finally free movement where you can
get there
[Music]
the little caves apartment is keeping
everyone is distracted lately okay
but all the rules still apply
don't muscle man
keep the energy going
you can tap you fight
[Music]
I don't have to go like
Oh
[Applause]
[Music]
nope
kid
[Music]
hiccup hey look same things up if I I'm
coming in which our disbanded yet that
that's a problem do you understand that
so you doing it
Jesus tenement sometimes you move the
arm keep keeps walking this way
we're not put that arm right underneath
its base before continuing unit and we
still have this office
so it's not it's the matter of almond a
yield Joey you can't yield learn East
and it goes okay you might hate that one
I think what you guys saw is that you
yielded here because the ballot was over
here you can come up to the head
okay so any move that you try to do they
got us walking here that's very low
percentage
you have to figure out how did you get
hit down
it's very subtle old home maybe I do it
with a strike
maybe I let it motion keep going lower
[Music]
I don't know what it's gonna be but I
know you're going to feel it
you're going to feel it
you can't get into this habit a
good attempt
the movement is warm
pummeled get there you got something
sometimes you'll get it go hi there any
pushes on me right well that's what I
needed whoa but I still have to find it
[Music]
I would like for you to
experiment with okay now I need to
change it spine angle
change is slight angle
changes bar
change its later
oops fighting
try to
feel their heart needles apart will give
computed all right scared it yet she
doesn't want to go off balance you can
but I don't need her to go off balance I
actually just need her to
do what
Kazushi does to people
right in his consciousness you go Eagle
attention you understand so it's the
attempt right there when she's in her
props her marks lock she's not fighting
anymore she is
defending herself
yet so I'm doing this I'm here boom I
got a free kick in
boom ha hey hey she's not fighting his
hands dead now see the heat over here it
ripped her out then I can get my
movement it but I don't want to hurt you
in this she goes hey you see now under
this he knows it see now she's captured
by five so I've come here full
don't need her to go down right she
going to go down what do you think move
she look out yes and he's about twenty
to thirty seconds so
don't let yourself get caught here
and then you know the other high coming
home
keep it moving full you'll find it you
might not look like the other two kids
could go to hang in there and they go
off balance well
okay
[Music]
yeah yielded
thank you
you